you were nominated multiple times and
you have now won
multiple billboard music awards how do
you feel crazy
crazy i don't feel like this is real i
don't know how to process this
it's overwhelming in the best way um
gosh
i got emotional on the stage all the
things you did you teared up what was
making you
cry in that moment um it's just kind of
like
i don't know when you step up there and
have the mic and it's like okay this is
your moment it's kind of like all your
hard work and like all the emotions that
kind of like
took you to get get there and blood
sweat and tears it kind of just like
hits you like a brick wall and you're
like whoa i'm actually here and it's
just like
floodgates blood sweat and tears feels
real for you you've done you've
had a baby you've gotten married you
worked hard to get your own record deal
like this has to be cool too to think i
know you mentioned your little girl's
watching at home
and she'll be able to see this one day
what does that mean to you oh it's so
special
she gets to see her mommy living out her
dreams and i hope it just
you know encourages her to dream big
towards things and that it's able to
happen you know
and i know i talked to you over the
weekend i think you won the one you kind
of wanted to win tonight yes
absolutely i mean there were so many
wonderful categories to be in so it's
just crazy
crazy now you're in the company with
some of your icons i'm sure yes
it was insane to have to be in the
category with carrie underwood and
marin morris and your man who's standing
behind the camera right now um
he was he's been walking with this dress
all night making sure you didn't fall
that's a gentleman
he's a sweetie yeah he is the best
seriously best friend ever
best partner i've ever loved so much can
we ask who you're wearing yes
nicholas chebron show me the back of
this dress by the way so there's
detail detail detail lots of sparkles
and
just lots of detail it had to feel good
we've seen the instagrams of you doing
your own laundry it had to feel good to
dress up tonight
yeah it felt pretty good i liked it my
mom is watching my daughter
and we're having a good time oh a little
date night a little date night a little
something
kate how proud of you how proud are you
dear extremely he says
can you can you just pop in for two
seconds are we allowed get in here come
on
i'm like thinking to myself get over
here i'm sorry i just i'm flashing back
to interviewing you two on the american
idol carpet
wondering if you were dating and now
here you are i know i know it she's just
beyond anything i could ever deserve
her dad told me he said you're a lucky
man and i said it's not luck it's
straight mercy from the lord that i get
to be married to her so i mean
she just just is just i mean you ought
to see her at home i mean she takes care
of me and that baby and
thank you you know and then she gets out
here and does all this i mean she's just
there's no way nobody like her i'm
convinced you know